man I cannot wait to find out what
happened to Luke Han and may half but
return to the jet episode 1 episode 1
does that mean the story's going
backwards literally and figuratively
also reading also I didn't read any of
that let alone comprehend it a New
Hope's first scene battle of Vader
overtaking Leia ship Empire's first
scene Hoth battle Return of the Jedi
first scene
Tatooine rescue but this movie's first
seen political ambassador is part of an
envoy to talk about trade blockades
funny since the days of episode 4 which
is technically after this movie's events
how much extra technology this era has
over its successor Israelis when our
high-ranking political guests have to
walk at the slowest pace of a droid like
this maybe we've taken the robot workers
concept too far I have a bad feeling
about this come with me if you want to
live also Liam Neeson isn't killing
anyone in this scene also god dammit the
stupid-ass rat tail I thought various
ponytails were for either preventing
hair from getting in the way were to be
cool this is neither discuss he mindful
of the Living force young padawan why
would the Chancellor send obvious Jedi
to the Trade Federation when it's pretty
obvious they would never agree to enter
the same room with him sending Jedi to
something like this is almost like
declaring war but at least make them not
dress like Jedi so it can be a surprise
eliminated blue eyes because killing
Jedi is easy we're on it boss
can you send gas to just one room when
you feed it into the air-conditioning
system or was this room created by
Spectre to execute people you don't like
on a whim not only does this asshole not
wait long enough for the Jedi to be dead
but he also thinks dead Jedi need
further destruction these mothers had
these Jedi in here all with pretty much
nowhere to go the room is filled with
gas they have no reason to open this
door at all even if you think they might
lightsaber their way through the door
why not just have your droids waiting to
gun them down as they did that check it
out corporal we'll cover you robot
soldiers have core please here's your
action in a nutshell Jedi mowing down
mindless minions making a mockery of
middling mechanisms are you going on Tom
though you might be expecting me to send
these characters obviously racist
accents and fun I will but I'm more
interested in sitting how an advanced
ship like this could possibly lose all
transmission from the affected area you
don't have a back-up camera or hallway
gear
why not just do that for the whole army
what did this exactly do anyway are they
dead unconscious are we about to see
them reboot like all terminators do all
this destruction and there isn't any
smoke scratch marks burns or anything
marking a battle took place other than
some ruined droids if you want to know
why subconsciously you were hating this
movie it's little details like that did
someone open a dusty chest where the
spare droid was just lying around
I pretty fly this is impossible
this guy doesn't understand what
impossible means more Jedi Master
destroy us this movie suddenly becomes
like a video game with the bad guys send
new enemies for the hero to fight but
just two of them so the game doesn't get
too challenging too fast are they
watching this footage in the door that
was nearly melted by qui-gon just a
second ago shoot some gas in there
I see they applied Natalie Portman's
board makeup oh wait let's not make up a
communications disruption can mean any
one thing
invasion what do you not know about
asteroids and other space anomalies our
communication is always perfect for you
assholes the senator would revoke that
trade franchise and they'd be finished
you're still talking about this why
didn't this movie start off with Jedi
doing real jedi thing with the political
theater firmly in the background gives
about this stuff
but I will condone this hairdo I'm
sporting which surely cost gobs of
government dollars but whatever I'm
guessing in 2019 George Lucas will want
to add some more lizards to this shot so
that will finally be complete this is
basically Jurassic avatar so look of
course we're going to raise this in
total by a hundred just because of Jar
Jar Binks but as we all know Jar Jar is
just a symptom of a far greater evil
going on with these movies blissfully
unaware of what makes a positive impact
glad we could see the camera follow this
chunk of sprites falling to the ground
to add to our enjoyment I think this
movie is discount Digga my scene was so
cheap it might as well be from
Spaceballs Jedi I can only go underwater
if you had the help of some they stole
from Q at mi6 Darger is the friendliest
song of the south character of the
modern era yousa goen tada bosses doo
doo this time yousa in big dudu dis time
you can see it right the green screen
studio Ewan McGregor and Liam Neeson are
standing in a droid army is about to
attack
we must warn resound or like wait I
thought Naboo was the name of the planet
you and the Naboo form a symbiont circle
what happens to one of you will affect
the other you must understand this it
appears that the Gungans and the Naboo
are completely separate from each other
these guys live in what is basically a
secret underwater city and do fine
without one another so I don't get it
a speediest way to the Naboo he's going
to be bland that cool this place is
basically earth right the planet core
isn't going to be ridiculously hot or
anything okay
also the whole reason the Clone Army
came down to Naboo was to fight the
people here but they decided to land on
the other side of the planet thing why
is it so we could see Star Wars turn
into Finding Nemo before Finding Nemo
existed he knows me would you call a
life-debt your gods demand that his life
belongs to me no I know this because I
know everything about your culture I
just learned existed five minutes ago
I mean seriously he just had this
exchange with obi-wan it's Master what's
a bongo transporter but now he's
suddenly an expert on Gungan law get out
of here you know some folks say Lucas
got bogged down in his world creation
with the prequels and those people are
onto something and not entirely wrong
this underwater craft built by an
underwater civilization has no mechanism
for detecting ginormous fish that might
be swimming behind it within swallowing
distance 20,000 Jedi under the sea a big
thing that ate a smaller thing gets
eaten by an even bigger thing cliche
we're not even 20 minutes in and these
hologram meetings make me want to stab
the movie screen with Twizzlers
I have the Senate bogged down in
procedures they will have no choice but
to accept your control of the system why
you didn't tell him about the missing
Jedi no need to report that to him until
we have something to report
and obviously the reigning Sith Lord
can't sense Jedi activity on his own so
we're gravy baby well this is a comic
don't worry the force will guide us the
force also guided you to nearly getting
eaten by a goober fish just a second ago
why don't we trust this force anyway
obi-wan fixes the ship by playing with a
couple of wires
seems legit relax qui-gon waits 20
minutes into this movie to do this why
are these invading ships attacking in a
straight line instead of a super wide
front Viceroy we have captured the Queen
[Music]
Victoria Wheatley captured the Queen
without a fight that's not so much of
victory as it is a forfeit jar jar a sub
containing two Jedi pops up to the
surface of a downtown Naboo waterway and
no one notices this is actually fake
Queen Amidala played by Keira Knightley
and this trailing servant is actually
Natalie Portman the real Queen which you
only really notice on your second or
third viewing but my question is what
are you doing watching this a second a
third time I'm curious about many things
in this shot most importantly the reason
why it looks fake ish these birds are
flying to join the Birdemic I'll let you
debate which movie is better you can
argue that it's a huge coincidence the
two Jedi show up in Naboo at the same
time the Queen is being whisked away and
at the same spot but someone's just
gonna show up in the comments schooling
you on midi-chlorians so why bother we
should leave the street your highness so
absolutely no one from the federation
except a bunch of droids we're ensuring
the Queen got to the right place they
need her to sign a treaty to make this
invasion of theirs legal they can't
afford to kill her what they mean her to
sign a treaty to make the invasion of
her home planet legal movie substitutes
the previous robot action scenes in like
we won't notice one ship is going to
attempt to go through a planetary
blockade with the Queen in tow in other
news I just beat LeBron James one-on-one
with one hand tied behind my back my
left shoe tied to my right shoe and
playing with a football when I was on
offense every Droid but r2d2 gets shot
off the surface of the ship like bottles
on Kid Rock's fence r2 though that there
was indestructible of course and that's
saying nothing about these droids crazy
ability to drive on the exterior surface
of a moving spaceship you can't get the
shield generator fixed we'll be sitting
ducks aren't you already you're right in
front of the blockade with a million
ships tearing you down how are they
missing you deflector shields up at
maximum so this movie is saying if you
have a shield generator you can easily
survive a blockade also once you escape
a planetary blockade no one comes after
you and one that designed why does it
matter if the treaty gets signed or not
aren't you evil do you care about laws
and also movie steals the treaty
excitement from one exciting treaty base
movie I wanna know how Holograms
actually work is there a booth you step
inside from the Emperor's perspective
does he see these two guys sitting down
as holograms on opposite sides of a
table if so what at this table is
broadcasting them all so what's up with
this hologram technology that Darth Maul
could be standing a few feet behind his
master and not be seen but step forward
and reveal himself
extremely well-put-together little droid
your highness the Queen has time to
recognize droid heroism r2d2 your
highness
yay r2d2 I remember that little guy I
completely forget that the first 28
minutes of this movie was about pre
disputes the hyperdrive generators gone
master we'll need a new one that'll
complicate things and the screenwriter
saw that it was good and it was good
we're on a stealth mission so let's
bring the slow asteroid in the clumsy
court jester Jar Jar brilliant fine even
if this movie is for kids even if Jar
Jar was made for kids no matter what
excuse you give me the stepping and
scene is basically a metaphor for the
whole franchise name one great kids
movie that has a scene like this go
ahead I'm waiting don't touch anything
Dictionary is unsatisfactory in coming
up with the right words of anger for
this scene are you an angel thus began
the least believable on-screen romance
since Anakin and Padme in attack of the
clones wait if you subscribe to the
brand-new and totally insane internet
theory that Jar Jar was originally
intended to be a Yoda like evil Jedi
Master this whole time how do you
explain this Three's Company book
credits will do fine no what do you
think you're some kind of Jedi waving it
around like that this didn't work
against Java and it didn't work against
this pissant so if the force is only
good against the weak-minded what good
is it it should be able to take down
some smarter creatures too if it's worth
a damn wouldn't have lasted long anyways
if I wasn't so good at building things
character backstory disguised as whining
is that Rito in the background why can't
that motherfucker be shooting his
trigger-happy gun right now when the
body meets a body coming through the CG
huh yes go Sebulba japako oh man DISA
aren't you supposed to be cleaning the
racks how did you get out of your child
labor obligations to go save Jar Jar
this storm will slow them down
looks pretty bad it does I mean I hear
wind sound effects and the picture is a
tiny bit blurry but as a viewer I've
been given no indication of a super
serious sudden sandstorm or its severity
when we have back to where Shu is Anakin
is allowed to walk around with qui-gon
everywhere he goes now because he saved
the most annoying character in the movie
from a fight how these characters all
end up together is hardly organic Jar
Jar does nothing except be oppressed so
they keep it
Anakin saves that asshole so they keep
it remember how Luke and Han became a
team it came out of need these
characters get to tag along because the
script says so
because sandstorms are very very
dangerous and this sandstorm happened to
coincide with the time when the Jedi and
company were humoring a little bored
tour guide the rest of all the Star Wars
can happen great
so Anakin built c-3po also the odds of
them being in the same narrative by the
time a new hope rolls around are
astronomical he takes a character
introduction that should feel epic and
makes it feel what's the opposite of
epic a death toll is catastrophic as is
this bill I just got for hologram
communications it's absolutely through
the roof Jar Jar misses the Apple but
he's definitely an asshole I'm the only
human who can do it
you must have Jedi reflexes if you race
bomb racing it's no different for NASCAR
or Formula One the only human you can do
it just another explanation for qui gonn
to recruit this kid into the Jedi
Academy the prize money would more than
pay for the parts they need basically
Star Wars turned into one of those 80s
sitcoms where the characters need
$10,000 and they find out there's a
dance competition where they can win
$10,000 he was meant to help you thank
god Jar Jar got curious about some
bullsh accidentally started a fight with
some asshole and Anakin was around to
save him even though I still don't think
he cleaned those racks hologram budget
exceeds 50 million what if this plan
fails master by the way a movie sticks
obi-wan on this ship doing nothing the
entire time on Tatooine that's exactly
what we wanted to see the badass
character from the original trilogy dude
now didn't we there's something about
this boy why can't they Jedi talk to
each other why do they need these little
radios who was his father there was no
father
Wow way to Jesus Christ the Anakin
character you know it would have been
way more interesting almost any
mysterious character from the galaxy
impregnating you and then leaving you
could have even made that a big surprise
reveal in the third movie somehow
anything about this quiet baby greed oh
you're lucky we even let you hold the
paddle this movie is officially coming
to a dead stop what's happened so far
twenty-eight minutes about taxes and
another 15 minutes or so of the brown
bunny when we watched Vincent Gallo
wash his car in real time 35 second long
conversation about midi-chlorians is 36
seconds too long they need a
midi-chlorian count hey you remember
when you watch the original trilogy and
you thought man if I could believe in
the force I could be a Jedi well turns
out Jedi creation depends on whether or
not you have a lot of something really
dumb called midi-chlorians in your
bloodstream how does an evil ship with a
Sith Lord on it land on this planet
without radar Jedi intuition picking it
up
as usual in these movies only the bad
guys have autonomous probes I wager my
new racing pod against say the boy and
his mother oh I see qui-gon either knows
for a fact that Anakin will win the race
or he's literally risking everything on
a hunch either way sit
qui-gon practises the Jedi way and
cheats at the dice throat he should just
use his Jedi powers to sabotage the race
if he's gonna subvert honesty anyway I
can show you they will never get me onto
one of those dreadful starships
I love how strange evil flying drones
are able to wander this planet without
anyone thinking it's weird or shady the
first Star Wars accomplished and
established more in 20 minutes than this
movie has in an hour here's a hundred
cents Sebulba sabotages Anakin's
podracer in front of thousands of
spectators yet no one sees a thing
you
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out